- Hey, everyone, this is
Jeremy with Khan Academy.
Thanks so much for joining
us on this Friday afternoon,
or Friday morning, depending
on where you're calling in from.
Wherever you're calling in from,
you're in for a special treat today,
because we have Matt,
one of our Khan Academy ambassadors
from Georgia, calling in
to share his expertise
on using Khan Academy with high schoolers.
And while I think Matt
would've been willing
to offer this at any time,
I have to give him special
thanks for doing it right now,
in the midst of this crisis
because Matt, like myself,
has two kids running around at home.
And so Matt is actually taking this call
from outside his home, just
so he can have some peace
and quiet to devote to you all today.
So as a quick reminder, the
way these sessions work,
is we're gonna get to know
Matt a little bit better.
Get some of his best tips
for using Kahn Academy
at the high school level,
and then once we have that,
we're gonna open it up
to questions from you,
right from the audience.
So if you wanna submit
those questions to Matt,
just go to the questions
tab of the Go to Webinar
control panel, and we'll take those
in the order they're received.
So any questions, start
submitting those now,
and we'll take those very soon.
But before we do, again
another shout to you, Matt,
for making time in your busy day,
your busy teaching schedule,
your busy home-front life.
And to just kick things
off, why don't you tell us
a little bit about your
background as an educator,
and how you got started with Kahn.
- Absolutely.
I appreciate Kahn Academy for having me,
and giving me this opportunity
to share some things with you.
So, my name is Matt Colbreth.
I have spent seven years
as a formal educator.
I have a batchelor degree
from Dalton State College,
with an education certification.
I'm about eight weeks out
from having a master's degree
in math education from Thomas University.
I spend my first three
years after I graduated
in Chattanooga Tennessee at a school,
East Hamilton Middle High school.
I taught seventh-grade math.
I also taught eighth-grade algebra,
and served as the middle
school boy's basketball coach,
and an assistant high
school basketball coach.
In 2016, I moved to my current employment
with Catoosa County schools
in Northwest Georgia.
I spent my first year
as a traveling teacher
between two schools, Lakeview
Fort Oglethorpe High School,
and then Ringgold High School.
After the first year,
Lakeview Fort Oglethorpe had a
full-time position available.
I was a half-time general ed math teacher,
and a half-time special ed math teacher,
and that's what I served
for the last three years.
I taught Algebra I, Algebra
II, Math of Finance,
Foundations of Algebra.
And at the general ed
and special ed levels.
I serve as the assistant
girl's basketball coach,
and assistant baseball coach.
I also am the Algebra I team facilitator
for our PLC group, our
Professional Learning Community.
And I serve on our response
intervention initiation team.
We're just now getting our
response intervention program
kind of kicked off.
And so I serve on that
team as an active member.
- Wow.
Matt, you are a man of many hats.
- (laughing) Done it for a little while,
and it's a joy, I mean,
I love being an educator.
I think it goes back to my, as a child,
I was one of the older of my cousins,
and had a large family, close-knit family,
but I wanted to see my younger siblings,
my younger cousins,
wanted to see them become
the best they could be.
And I still kind of hold
that true to now my students.
I just kind of carried on
as, I guess, my calling.
- Very cool.
Well, I know they need you
more than ever right now.
So, thanks for all that you're doing.
And just to sort of dive
into this question using
Kahn Academy in the midst of all of this,
how do you normally use Kahn Academy?
How thank you typically integrate
it into your day-to-day?
- So, my students usually
see some sort of Kahn Academy
almost every day, pretty much every day.
At the beginning of the year,
I assign them a Mastery Challenge,
so, with my Algebra I class,
which is typically what I teach,
I will assign Algebra I
Mastery, the course mastery,
usually in early August or September.
So when I do that, that allows
them to see their progress,
and allows them to really
work towards a goal.
And we set bi-weekly goals
to have them achieve that
course mastery by the end of the year.
So, I see you're kind of going
through some of the things
to set up that course mastery
and once you get everything set up,
it's really not a hard task,
but it gives you so many
things to be able to to see
how well your students are
progressing throughout the year.
- Yeah, and just sort of explain
for teachers who are coming
from more of an assignments
mindset to this mastery mindset,
what is course mastery
and why is it important?
- So through the course
mastery, it used to be done
with what they called Missions.
And we've kind of moved
into the course mastery, but
the idea is that everything,
especially mathematically,
everything is built upon each other.
You have to have good foundations
before you can begin
building on top of that.
I've heard Sal say in
some of his TED talks,
if you're building a house,
you don't have an inspector
come in and say, "Oh,
well your foundation,
"it's got 80% passes code.
"We can start building the first level
"and the second level."
Eventually that crashes down.
So idea of course mastery
is that you work through
different units and different
lessons, and different levels
of whatever subject it is, right?
So if it's for Algebra I,
it begins with an algebra
foundations piece, unit,
and you work through that
algebra foundations unit,
and you gain points for
assignments that you complete,
and questions that you answer correctly.
And you continue moving through that unit
until you've completed it.
It has some quizzes available in it.
It has unit tests available for each unit.
And with that, students
earn points every time
they complete these with accuracy.
And they will level up
and eventually get to that mastery point.
- Absolutely.
So basically, what you're setting out
at the beginning of the
regular school year is,
"Hey, we have a high bar,
"not just to get through the textbook,
"but to master each foundational
skill along the way."
And Course Mastery kind of
drives them to that high bar.
Now, let me sort of
switch gears a little bit.
That's all well and
good if it's September,
if it's normal times, now that it's April,
and it's this strange new
world that we're living in,
if you were just starting
with Kahn Academy
as a high school teacher today,
what are the one or two
things that you would do
just to get a quick win next week?
Just to get some wind behind your back?
- Well I think the first
thing that you need to do
is to be able to set up your classes.
And so, when you sign in,
when you sign up as a teacher,
you will see this screen,
as this is kind of your teacher dashboard.
And so to set up your class,
we're lucky in Catoosa County
that we all have different classrooms,
and so Hahn Academy does sync directly,
will pull in rosters from Go Classroom.
And so, all you have to do is
click on the Add New Class,
and if you have Google
Classroom, you can actually
import your class directly
from Google Classroom
and your rosters are automatically
put into Kahn Academy.
And so you don't have to do a whole lot.
If you don't have the Google
Classroom already set up,
then can enter your class name,
and then you have to add
courses for your class.
For instance, mine is Algebra I.
And I do typically go back and maybe add
like a pre-algebra course to it,
just so I see those whenever
I make an assignment.
See those lessons.
But you can choose
whatever courses you like,
mathematics, or anything.
And then to add your
students, like I said,
for Google Classroom users,
it's very, very simple,
just connect to your Google Classroom.
They can also use the class,
like a share a link with their students.
And ostensibly click on that link
and they will automatically be joined.
I've been using Kahn
Academy for years and years,
and so when I was doing middle school,
I would used to create the
student accounts for them.
Because this was before I had
any sort of Google Classroom.
And so I would create
the student's accounts,
put their names in.
It would give me a user
name and a password.
And I would share that with the student,
and that's how they would
get on Kahn Academy.
- That's great.
So multiple ways to get started.
And then just sort of take
this through to the next step.
Like let's say you've
built out your class,
you've invited your students,
what do you do to just
sort of get a little bit
of expertise under the student's belt?
- So, the assignments tab,
I do you use quite often.
So, when you click on the classroom,
you get into the screen that you're in,
under the assignments,
and you click to assign,
it has the entire course,
every unit, and everything
built underneath that.
And so, you can assign an entire unit,
as Jeremy has done here.
He's clicked on the check mark.
And you can assign entire units.
If you don't want the entire unit,
if you just want to chunk it,
which is what I typically do,
you may find a lesson that
will assign a few videos,
or a few practice assignments.
Or you may just want to assign
one practice assignment.
And those are indicated
with the pencil mark
over on the left-hand side.
You can click on the assignment
of see what kind of question
it's actually going to be asking,
and make sure that that is what you want.
And one of the great
things, in my opinion,
that the assignment, the exercise do,
is generally, I don't
believe there's any exercise
that has more than seven
or eight questions in it.
And so it's nothing that is
overwhelming to the student.
And they're good, quality questions.
So, you get a good idea of
what your student does know,
or doesn't know, but it's
not going to take them
an hour and half to complete.
So, once you've decided
what you want to assign,
you click on the Assign button,
and you have some different options there,
you can have that each student does
a different set of questions.
Most of the questions I've
seen banks of upwards around
40 and 50 question in each set.
Or you can have all students
do the same questions.
There's been a lot of times
that I have students
do the same questions,
for the fact that I can have them
either do that at the end
of class, or for homework,
something of that nature.
And then later in the
class, or the next day,
we can come together.
And we use their information,
how they answered those
questions, and we talk about
why this was a good answer,
why this was a bad answer.
And it's not just to
give me a number grade
to put in the grade book.
- Very cool.
Go for it, Matt.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
So the other great thing
that I like under this screen
is that under the student's tab,
you can select to send it to all students,
but there have been many
times where I've wanted
to maybe differentiate,
or some students have
mastered a certain skill,
and I may only choose a few students,
two or three students to
send an assignment to.
And especially, we use this
a lot with our RTI program.
We use the MAP test,
and use the way Kahn Academy links to it,
so there a lot of times
where not every student
needs that assignment,
so I will only assign to a few students.
- Beautiful.
And you can set your
due date and your time.
And so it goes out to the students,
what do the students see?
Can you talk a little bit
about that experience?
- Absolutely.
So if you go back to the top,
or to the teacher dashboard,
so at your home, you can
click on your user name,
or your name in the top right-hand corner,
and it will show you the Learner Home.
And under Learner Home, that
kind of gives you a view
of what the students are going to see.
And when the students
log into Kahn Academy,
once you have given an assignment,
or you have given a Course Mastery,
on the left-hand side,
all of their classes,
so they can be enrolled
in multiple classes.
I know our World History
teacher, has just recently
started using Kahn Academy
quite a bit for his class.
So beyond the math classroom.
And their assignments, and
their classes all show up
on the left-hand side.
If they have a Course Mastery goal,
the Course Mastery shows up there.
Also, the assignment shows up there.
And if the assignment is past due,
it shows up under the Past tab.
If it's still an active assignment,
Then it would obviously show up under
the Active Assignment tab.
- So a student clicks into an assignment,
and says, Mr. Colbreth
has just assigned to me.
They see it on their screen.
How do you typically recommend
that students use this?
Like, do they just go through in one shot?
Do they do it multiple times?
Do they get support?
- I think this is one
of the toughest things
to get across to students,
is using some of the supports
that Kahn Academy offers.
I started using Kahn Academy
way back when it was just
YouTube videos, and the videos
are some of the best help
that I think the students can get.
If I can get them to use it.
Whenever they give it their best try,
and they don't get a question right,
they can get help.
And they have either
hints available to them,
or video content that
is available to them.
And I'll even tell
students, "If you missed
"one or two questions, even
if you try it your first time,
"or you don't try, you just
have no idea what it is,
"use those videos, use those hints,
"to help you understand the material."
They're reluctant to do
that because they don't like
to get questions wrong.
But, I tell them, "If you can learn it,
"then learning it is much more important
"than one correct answer."
- Absolutely.
Definitely lean on Kahn
Academy to give that live,
real-time feedback if you can't be there
to give it yourself.
And then to just sort of
bring it to full circle,
back to the teacher view,
We'll take questions from
the audience in one second.
Once your students have started
to complete these exercises,
where are you looking
to sort of understand what's happening?
- Yeah, so in the classroom,
on the classroom page,
you have to, under the assignments,
there's a tab for Scores.
So you'll click on the Scores tab,
and it will give you the
scores for each student
for wherever assignments you have.
So you can look at that,
and then if you want to
look at individual reports,
you can click on the actual
score for that student.
So you can, when you click on the score,
it will show you what
questions they've attempted.
How they answered them.
Which ones the got correct,
which one they got wrong.
And I know up for the attempt,
a lot of times I will look
at their first attempts
to see how they kind of have
answered it to begin with,
and what their initial thinking was,
and then their last attempt is really
how they completed the question.
The other place that I have
started recently using,
and this is fairly new, new to me,
is under the classroom page,
is the activity overview.
And here you can look at how much time
students are spending on Kahn Academy,
what skills are they practicing.
How many skills are they leveling up.
And you can also look
at individual students.
Look at really the activities
they're doing on Kahn Academy.
So when you click on that student's name,
it will show you a lot
more in-depth information
about what the student
is doing on Kahn Academy.
You can also see individual
student assignments
from that page, and the time
they're spending, as well.
- That's great.
So I think that's
probably more than enough
for a week or two of just getting adjusted
to the Kahn Academy.
Let's pause there,
and analyze sort of the
reality of the situation,
because we can go on to probably
three hours of in-depth advanced tips.
Let's just take the
questions from the audience,
and see where people's minds are at.
So, first question is
coming in from Belinda.
And Belinda asks a
really important question
that sort of goes beyond the technology.
"What are your suggesting, Matt,
"for how to handle progress for students
"who are not doing assignments,
even over extended periods?
"I know we are in very,
very unusual times, now,
"but how would you recommend
handling your student
"who is just not making any
progress in Kahn Academy?"
- Well I think one of the
things is the communication
between the teacher and the student.
And so during a normal
time, if I see that students
are not making progress,
I have a conference with that student.
I talk with that student.
And I think there is a,
you know, Kahn Academy
is not a babysitter.
And it's not a replacement for me.
I still have that
relationship with the student.
And I speak with them to try to motivate,
find that motivation for
why is this important?
Why do you need this?
What kind of correlation
does it have to your lives?
And now in these times, I
still am trying to find ways
to communicate with students,
whether it be through email messages,
or I use an app, a Remind app,
that allows me to send
messages via text to students.
And so, I still try to find
those ways to communicate,
and really drill down the
importance of the assignment.
And hopefully, use my
relationship with them
to drive that forward.
- Great, great.
Yeah, I think even in these
extenuating circumstances,
communication with
students is still the key
to pretty much all great teaching.
And even if it's
communication over an app,
or a video conference, or whatever,
reaching out beyond just,
"Hey, here's an assignment,"
it's so important.
Speaking of that, Sandy
has a question for you
that kind of extends that question.
"What if you have students
who are not only struggling
"with grade-level material,
but actually have big gaps
"in their foundations?
"They're already coming
to you in high school
"many years behind.
"Is there any opportunity to use Kahn
to help catch them up?"
- Absolutely.
And I'm glad you said that
because one of the great things
that we have been doing at
LSO that I'm have proud of,
is our RTI program, our Response
to Intervention program.
And if you try to research
and find many resources
on high school RTI programs,
there's not a lot out there.
We couldn't find any.
So, Kahn Academy, in a
partnership with the NWEA,
and MAP testing is one thing
that we have used this year.
And so, we gave our
students the MAP assessment
at the beginning of the year,
which kind of diagnoses and
tells us exact where they're at.
And we have students all the way down,
coming into ninth grade,
all the way down on a fourth
and fifth grade level,
on certain MAP skills.
And so we set up little
classes for them during our
guided studies time, and really
during our flex lunchtime.
And we use Kahn Academy to
reach back into those fourth
and fifth grade concepts, and reteach,
and try to solidify
that, because as we said,
if you do not have those foundations,
it's hard to build off it.
So, we use the data that we
gathered from the MAP test,
to identify what content
we needed to focus on
for those students, and
then used Kahn Academy
to help teach and assess
students on those concepts.
- I love that.
It's such a powerful sort of way
to make sure that each student
is getting what they need
not just whatever your pacing
guide is telling you today.
Did you use the Mappers
tool, out of curiosity, Matt?
- I certainly did.
So I searched Mappers,
and really it will pop up.
There it is.
And so when you go in, if you
classes are already set up,
you can enter the MAP scores.
If you have used the MAP test,
and you enter the MAP scores
for the data that you have,
for the students that you have,
and then it will give you a recommendation
for what concepts those
students need to be working on.
- Very cool.
So, just pasting that link into chat box.
So if anyone is using the MAP
assessment in their school,
they can definitely
take advantage of that.
Here's another important
question about differentiation.
Christina says, "For
special education students
"at the high school level, how
do you make accommodations?
"Would you recommend making
special worksheets for them?
"Pulling these questions
out of Kahn Academy?
"How do you serve that
audience, in particular?"
- So, a lot of times I limit
the number of questions,
the number of assignments
that I do with them.
We do a lot, really just as a class.
So we might present questions
up on the board, as a class,
and then kind of walk
through that all together.
Not as much as an independent activity.
I also have a limited use of iPads.
And one thing I found that a
lot of my students like to do
is use the iPad because they can touch it,
and they can draw on it,
and they can, the Kahn
Academy app allows you
to use an info tool, and
actually show some work on it.
And for whatever reason,
it does tend to engage
the students a little bit more.
I think that there are
certain accommodations
that you can provide there,
but again, I will interject and say
the teacher is probably
the most important tool
that you have,
so using the thing that you know,
and the strategy that you
have to blend the two,
between Kahn Academy and the things
that you were doing in the classroom
are crucial to the sort of intervention.
- My apologies there.
I was just sort of showing off.
One way to sort of draw,
even if you don't have fancy technology.
In that assignment score report
that Matt had talking about
a couple of minutes ago,
you could actually share
this screen on a Zoom call,
or Google Hangout call with your students,
and walk through live how
you might solve a problem
step-by-step.
So, just another way to
build that communication line
to your students.
Let me ask another really
important question from Bryce.
Bryce says, "How do you
typically grade MAP?
"Do you take scores
from Kahn into account?
"Do you build your own assessments?
"How does Kahn fit into that?"
- Great question, 'cause we've
been having this discussion
in our school about grading
and what grades should look
like extensively here recently.
So, our subject area,
our Algebra I teachers
have recently decided that we are grading,
for the most part, on course mastery.
So based on the assessments that we give,
and whether that be a formative assessment
through Kahn Academy, or a
paper and pencil assessment,
a unit test, we take those
grades, and we base it,
whatever our learning target
is, we base it on a scale
of one to four.
Whether it's one being a
beginning-level learner,
or four being a master-level learner,
or somewhere in between.
And that makes up 70%
of our grading process.
So there could be some times
where the Kahn Academy,
like I said, this is a
formative assessment,
but a lot of times, most of
it, I use for the other 30%,
my daily grades that I take.
And I use the grades that they
have made on the assignments,
but I allow unlimited number of attempts.
Because I don't, I'm not worried that
a student doesn't know it on Monday,
if they know it on
Friday of that same week.
Or even if it takes them
two weeks to learn it.
My goal is by the time
they leave my class,
that they understand the
material and the content
that I'm wanting to teach,
regardless of how long
it takes them to learn that.
- I love that.
Yeah, and I've heard that from
so many other educators recently.
The Kahn Academy is not
about whether you're
"Getting an A or a B,"
but whether you had that growth mindset.
Are you constantly pushing yourself
towards that mastery goal,
even if it's a really
long stretch for you?
And so using that sort
of look at the progress
they're making can be even more important.
Really important question from Sandy.
Sandy says, "Hey, you
know, if we're trying to
"figure out where students are,
"they've obviously been away
from their regular routines
"for a little while, and want to do
"maybe some kind of baseline diagnostic,
"is there anyway to do something similar
"to that in Kahn Academy?
"Just to get a sense of where
students are at right now?"
- I would say that's a good question.
And I may not know a perfect answer to it.
One thing I have used to
maybe as like a pretest
is the course challenges,
or the unit test,
for then each of the subject areas.
So, say we were in a unit of quadratics
before we left for our extended break,
and so I used, under the quadratics unit,
at the very bottom, there's a unit test,
and you can assign that unit test,
and it will cover everything
that's within that unit.
And you can see what
questions students get right,
and get wrong.
- That's great, yeah.
I think that's the easiest
way to quickly figure out
what are the skills that they are lacking,
where they are strong, and
then pinpoint as you make
those differentiation assignments,
as Matt talked about.
That's great.
Let's see here.
This is sort of a basic
question about just making
sure that assignments are on target.
Ayomi wants to know,
"Matt, is there any way
"to change the due date of an assignment
"after I assigned it?"
- Great question because I've
done this multiple times.
Many, many time.
Yeah, so under the Assignment Plan,
when you go to, instead
of the Assignor Scores,
you can go to Manage, and
on the far right-hand side,
you can click the Actions,
and the Edit button.
And that will allow you to change,
if you want to add students through that,
you can do that.
Again, there's the change
the due date, and the time.
And you click Save Changes,
and the changes will be made.
And another probably similar question
is that what happens when you
have a new student come in?
We're a very transient school,
and so I had multiple times
where I had a new student come in,
and so I would add them
to my Google Classroom,
and then re-sync on Kahn
Academy, under the Settings tab.
You can update sync with Google Classroom.
Once that is done, when you go
back to the Assignments tab,
it will give you a prompt
asking you if you want
to reassign the assignments
that are active currently
to the new student.
And all you have to do
is put Saved, or Yes,
and it will allow you to reassign
or give those assignments to
the new student walking in.
- Cool.
And then, another really sort of important
foundational question from Phil,
"Okay, so I'm curios to
do these assignments,
"but I wanna actually
understand what I'm assigning
"before I give it out.
"Is there some way for me, the teacher,
"to review the course,
or review the exercise
"before it goes out to my students?"
- Absolutely.
So under the Assign tab,
you can scroll through
the entire course, as we had said before,
the videos, if you click
on the link for the videos,
it will take you directly to that,
and you can watch the
video in its entirety.
For the exercises and the articles,
you can view the article
by clicking on the tab.
For the exercise, it
shows you the complete set
of list of questions to see
what that would look like.
And then you can also
click on the student view,
to see what it will look
like for the student.
Another thing on the
Assignments is that I've had
a lot of teachers who don't necessarily,
for whatever reason, they
don't like looking through
that the entire list for a
specific thing that they know
that they want to assign.
So they will use the search
bar up at the very top.
And they may search quadratic equations.
And once they find,
so they know exact what they want
to assign to their students.
They just need to find it.
And they'll use that search bar,
they'll find the exercise
that they want to use,
and they will click on it.
And I've used this quite often too.
The tab at the top now
allows you to Assign
that specific assignment to
students through that method,
once you see the student
view on the screen.
So you can still have the same options,
and assign it in that way.
- I love that.
Because I feel like it can
be totally overwhelming
to look at that massive
list of skills and videos
on the course.
If you can come out with
one skill, or one video,
search for that thing you want,
and then click the blue bar
to go right to the assignment piece.
Okay. I know we're running out of time,
so I want to finish up
with three question,
starting with a really
great one that I received
from Rose, an eighth grader.
Again, these webinars are
promoted very broadly.
Rose says, "I'm an eight-grader,
who's getting ready
"for high school next year.
"And I'm worried with this
whole thing happening,
"you know, with school being
closed, how can I be ready?
"How can I prepare?"
As a high school teacher speaking
to a future high schooler,
what advice would you give
Rose for really making sure
she's ready for prime time, hopefully,
knock on wood, come September.
- Yeah, the first thing I
would say, Rose could you,
if you want to move to
northwest, Georgia and come
to my classroom, it sounds
like you're a great student.
(Jeremy laughs)
- (laughing) That is awesome
that you're concerned with it.
But using Kahn Academy,
my suggestion would be
to go into the courses in
the top left-hand corner,
and choose, like at our
school, we move into Algebra I.
So if you're moving into
Algebra I, select the course
that are wanting to do, or that
you're gonna be moving into,
and begin at that first unit,
and work your way through it.
Use the videos as a help.
Like I said, I started with
Kahn Academy on YouTube,
and using videos to help me
kind of solidify the things
that I was hearing in class.
But even as a first
instruction, those videos,
they're great instructional videos,
and I highly recommend
them, to watch through them,
and practice your exercises.
And one thing we have not touched on is
the Mastery Challenges
that are somewhat new to Kahn Academy.
So whenever you click on that course page,
at the top, you will
receive a Mastery Challenge.
A lot of times I have my students do that,
maybe as a warm-up, when
they come in in the morning,
or through out day, when
they finish an assignment,
to go work on their course
math, their Mastery Challenge.
And this is just a style
review for all the things
that you have covered to
just read this and make sure
you've not forgotten the things
that you have done through Kahn Academy.
- All right.
Great advice for Rose.
And, Rose, we wish you good luck.
I know it's a hard time right
now, but think of joining us.
And I have a feeling that
there are awesome Mr. Colbreths
in your future in high school.
So more support to come.
Second question for you,
Matt, is I know we haven't
been able to cover every
question that came in right now,
if educators are still hungry for answers
after the session, where would
you recommend they go next?
- Well, a couple of different
places that I would say is,
one is, first I would say,
on your teacher dashboard,
I directed a lot of
teachers to this point,
is the Resources tab.
And there's a lot of good videos,
underneath that resources tab,
especially for getting started.
So if your really new to it,
and you want to look at
some different things,
check all of those out.
If you run into a specific question,
or something that you need to ask,
underneath your name in
the top right corner,
when you click on it,
there is a help section.
So you can click on that
help section, and your
questions are sent directly
to Kahn Academy experts
who get back to you quite quickly.
You just have to report
the problem at the top.
And I've had good experience with that.
The last area that I would
recommend everyone joining
is a Facebook page.
And it is Kahn Academy for teachers,
and I'm a member there.
And I tend to, I look at almost daily,
and just see some of the conversations
that are going on there.
But there are a magillion great
Kahn Academy teachers that
use Kahn Academy on there
and can answer a lot of
questions that you have.
- All right.
Awesome.
I'm just sharing all those
resources in the chat.
So if you want to get the resources,
if you want to get the request
help from Kahn Academy,
or join the Facebook group,
all of that is in your chat.
And the last thing, Matt, I know that
you've already shared a ton.
But if you have any final words of wisdom
for educators out there
across the country,
as they're thinking about,
"Oh my goodness, I've
got at least a couple
"of more weeks to go,
probably many more than that,
"how do I make the most of this time?
"How do I support my
students and their families?"
Any sort of sage advice you can share?
- I have just, one, tried to
not get overwhelmed by it all.
Make sure you're taking care of yourself,
and taking care of your
immediate family first,
because if you are not in good health,
then there's no way you
can help anyone else.
So take care of yourself.
But two, just try to keep at some sort of
a communication line
open with your students.
I think that is the most important thing,
that students can know that you are there,
that you are available to them.
And the content will start to,
once they have that relationship,
and they know that you're looking
after their best interest,
the content side of it starts
to kind of fall into place.
- I love that, yeah.
It's almost like the advice
we give to new parents.
You've got to take care of yourself
before you can take care of your kids.
The same is doubly true for educators.
- Absolutely.
- So Matt has given us tons of new wisdom
to pursue these big challenges
we have ahead of us.
He's also given us the strength to do it
at a time when we need it the most.
So I want to thank you, Matt,
for sharing all your expertise today.
And I want to thank everyone
out there listening in
for investing in the session.
And I wish you tremendous
success in the weeks to come.
Thank you so much, and
have a great weekend, all.
- Thank you, all.